[Music]
so I don't want to go into the history
there's actually really neat history of
exactly why and how a particular set of
ideas became so important in the latter
half of the 20th century I'll give you
just one example but the idea of
operational management which was
innovated during the heat of World War
two and largely to do things like make
strategic decisions about how we were
going to go about moving ships across
the Atlantic or run bombing raids on
Germany using statistics and actually
the applying statistics to analyze the
effectiveness of different approaches
and then therefore making decisions
based on statistics and so operational
management was very effective in the
military theater and the people who had
learn those techniques after war
percolated out into the broader economy
and start applying those techniques and
things like deciding how to run their
businesses so that's that's the basic
framework of the order that we built up
until now now the idea of the blue
church is trying to get a sense of what
it is that the essence of the control
structure but control I don't mean
necessarily anything bad I just mean the
mechanism by which we're able to make
collective decisions and engage in
effective collective action and the
thing that holds our decision in action
structure together the control structure
that still is the one that we're
operating under that came out of that
timeframe and the proposition is that in
addition to this is one piece but it's a
very important piece that there's a
dominant role is played by the structure
of media oh yeah we're actually you know
in the process of breaking that apart
right here so this is good we we know
that there's a particular dynamic
associated with the kinds of media that
are broadcast where one individual or
group because of the nature of the
medium so for example broadcast
television in the day of three networks
there was only three people who got to
be the anchors who communicate it out to
the entire population is a massive
asymmetry but
the speaker and the listener and there's
no interaction and so I am in a position
of listening your two positions speaking
and there's 30 million of me and one of
you right now that's actually a very
important dynamic if you don't
understand the fact of that and its
importance you're going to have a very
hard time understanding what actually
happened is during the latter half of
the 20th century as in particular
television emerged as a dominant medium
displacing radio and newspapers and by
the way you also have a hard time
understanding what's happening now as
the Internet is now emerging as the
dominant media replaced in television
just understanding that transition what
it implies means at a deep level is a
sort of fundamental for predicting
future States so using sort of
television as the metaphor I then looked
back and said all right are there other
things that we see that look like that
it's actually quite interesting that for
example school has a very similar shape
to it in the sense that you've got one
speaker a large audience and very little
interactivity particularly like the
university setting with is a lecture and
there's 500 people in the lecture hall
that is effectively the same thing as
television in the sense that the the
relationship of information flow is
effectively the same this is important
both from the sort of social dynamics as
well as from the psychological dynamics
because if as a child your primary
relationship to how you engage in
culture is one of almost certainly being
a pure receiver then your psychological
development your set of assumptions and
habituation and how you adapt to the
world will be associated with that
environment while you're adapting to
your local environment
and this implies a certain set of sort
of deep psychological structures so we
get is a relationship between the the
mechanisms and techniques and
potentialities of broadcasts as a as a
concepts of school television film the
blank and the the behavior strategies
the habits and even the capacities of
the individuals in the social layer so
when you get to the to the mid late 90s
you're actually dealing with the society
that could be understood as the Society
of broadcast
and that has implications for how
decisions are made and so the Society of
broadcast is characterized by what you
might call the mini Encyclopedia
Brittanica model or the walter kronkite
model where you have a set of
hierarchical structures where the
individuals who have permission
authority and responsibility for
speaking for having authority are
selected in some fashion to be
positioned at the top of the broadcast
hierarchy and then the rest of us defer
to them so somebody has written an
article in Encyclopedia Britannica or
some group of people some group of
experts who have been nominated in some
fashion to be positioned as experts and
at best take that responsibility very
seriously they pull the the total set of
questions back into their centers of
excellence in having conversations and
academic environments and you know
groups to get together instinct tanks
they produce an authoritative statement
of what is in fact our collective
opinion around this particular object
they then disseminate it through a
broadcast medium and the rest of us
listen to it cohere around it and say ok
that's what we do and then move forward
this is actually a very powerful
mechanism because it allows us to
simultaneously have hundreds of millions
of people broadly share the basic set of
assumptions about the nature of the
world the nature of what effective
action looks like even values what is
important what's not important so a
major piece not the only piece but a
major piece of the transition that we're
going through is precisely the fact that
a decentralized communication
infrastructure sometimes known as the
internet and all the manifestations and
mobile everything else radically changes
that dynamic so the internet is
characteristically symmetrical meaning
that the number of people who can speak
is effectively everyone obviously
there's not a even distribution of
audience along among everyone but it's
not structurally locked in and the
relationship between speaking and
receiving has become intrinsically or at
least intuitively bi-directional now
this shift implies a very large number
of differential consequences so we can
we can graph in the notion
the impact that it has on power and the
relationship between decision making and
action taking but there's also the
impact that it has on psychology and the
intuitive sense of the way that your
brain and the infective industry sort of
way that you go about making decisions
in the world actually has to adaptively
change so the people who grew up in the
post internet environment have a
fundamentally different psychological
set of structures like deep habitual
architectures and expectations of how to
most effectively present themselves in
the world then people who grew up before
them so what that will mean is two
things
one is the set of techniques and
approaches that socially evolved in the
television and the broadcast era are
suddenly maladaptive in this new
psychological ecosystem and so think
like the Pepsi commercial that so
famously was a disaster right that's
very much the kind of thing that is
produced by a broadcast intuition and we
get to send messages and those message
are things that you can see but the
psychology and the technology of the
internet or of this the decentralized
asymmetrical medium is one of no no we
get to critique we get to directly
respond to and things that feel like
they are broadcasters feel like they are
quite obviously intending to influence
us emotionally we know what that feels
like
and it doesn't it doesn't work anymore
so we're going to respond to that and
our ability to respond swarms around it
and breaks it up and so this for example
is I think at least a reasonably good
explanation for what's been happening in
the political domain over the past 30 or
40 years and certainly over the past two
[Music]